[Music]  Academy award-winning actor Jeff Bridges  turned 63 and I thought wouldn't be cool  let's try and get him on the show and  celebrate his birthday in person but  he's out of town he is not in Los  Angeles at the moment but we do have a  guy on our staff special effects  coordinator Erik Allard who looks a lot  like Jeff Bridges especially if you  squint your eyes so Allan could you  please squint the cameras eyes for me  that's great yeah that's great all right  terrific ladies and gentlemen here he is  happy birthday as far as you know Jeff  Bridges  [Applause]  [Music]  thanks cousin really appreciate it  yeah take care  we don't have to book real celebrities  anymore yeah  the staff look-alike